elle savait si un tonneau bonjour et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors la crise sanitaire a fait
augmenter le nombre de bénéficiaires du
secours populaire comment est-ce que
vous gérer cette explosion des besoins
depuis quelques mois bonjour c'est une
des grandes questions c'est être cette
adaptation que nous devons avoir
toujours par rapport à l'évolution des
mesures qui nous permettent d'accueillir
les gens nous continuons d'apporter
surtout une aide qui tant en termes de
besoins vitaux comme sur l'aide
alimentaire sur l'aide vestimentaire et
de juste après l'été nous avons aussi
remis en place toutes les questions
d'accompagnement puisque si on répond
aux besoins des tours il ya aussi toute
la question de l'accès au droit ou du
non accès au droit qui peut aussi
précipité les personnes dans les
situations de pauvreté
alors on a vu aussi un nouveau public
venir vous sollicitez qui sont ils
mais alors c'est pas un nouveau public
ce sont des nouveaux publics
effectivement que nous que nous
rencontrons au sein de nos de l'ensemble
de nos permanences d'accueil et de
solidarité
il y a eu forcément les foyers
monoparentaux les femmes seules avec
enfants qui ont dû dès le début du
confinement faire face à des
problématiques budgétaires notamment
avec la fermeture des écoles et puis
surtout les délais de la cantine les
donc c'était une vraie difficulté et
même si les choses sont revenues depuis
la rentrée scolaire
ça a créé aussi des déficits dans leur
budget et qu'ils sont difficiles
toujours aujourd'hui de pouvoir résoudre
nous avons eu aussi des auto
entrepreneurs nous avons aussi beaucoup
de personnes qui sont salariés notamment
dans le cadre de la restauration et qui
sont toujours dans la tente de pouvoir
exercer leur métier
et puis les mois passent et plus les les
droits ou les fans droit arrive nous
avons une grosse inquiétude aussi dans
le cadre des de l'ensemble des bilans à
des fermetures d'entreprises qui peuvent
se faire et s'il y aura pendant quelques
mois des indemnisations qui est qu'en
sera-t-il après pour toutes ces
personnes qui arrivaient à s'en sortir
qu'il y avait un emploi qui arrivait à
tenir l'ensemble de leurs charges et qui
commence dès
aujourd'hui à faire à devoir faire des
choix et un dernier public ce sont les
jeunes alors que soit soir les jeunes
qu'ils soient encore dans les études et
qui eux depuis le début est aujourd'hui
sont dans une extrême grande fragilité
de pauvreté mais aussi une fragilité
psychologique car se retrouvent depuis
de très nombreux mois sans liens sociaux
et puis ceux qui ont moins de 25 ans et
qui cherchent un emploi
et aujourd'hui on vous constate que
voilà le marché de l'emploi extrêmement
fermé et ils n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir par mm
il n'arrive plus à voir cette autonomie
et pour certains c'est à nouveau la
solidarité familiale qui doit s'exercer
quand elle peut se faire ailleurs
parallèlement à cette augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires ces profils
différents est ce que les dons
augmentent également pour le secours
populaire depuis le début de la crise
nous avons été ouverts dès le lendemain
des annonces du mois de mars nous avons
essayé d'adapter nous avons adapté notre
solidarité nous avons gardé nos portes
ouvertes et nous avons pu avoir de la
part de donateurs fidèles mais aussi de
nouveaux donateurs
un soutien qui nous a permis justement
de répondre à ses besoins vitaux de
pouvoir acheter de quoi permettre de
faire des aides alimentaires dini
conséquente de pouvoir re proposer aussi
des d'autres formes de solidarité
nous sommes dans notre campagne d père
noël vert en ce moment à le vert quand
on est un peu une couleur de l'espoir
c'est ce pourquoi le père noël du
secours populaire porte cette couleur et
avec les dons que nous avons nous
permettons aussi dans ces tentes fin
d'année de donner un peu autre chose de
garder quand on peut le faire des
moments conviviaux mais surtout de
penser aux familles de penser aux
personnes seules d'apporter par
différentes formes des cadeaux ou autres
qui seront aussi un petit bol d'oxygène
dans cette fin d'année et qui
permettront de panser certes aux besoins
vitaux mais aussi te de souffler un
petit peu nous l'espérons pour ces
millions de personnes
dernière question très rapidement vous
êtes soutenus par les pouvoirs publics
également dans les pouvoirs publics ont
fait différentes annonces depuis le
début du confinement du mois de mars
ce sont des annonces qui se sont faits
dans sur différents plans nous
constatons que ces aides qui ont pu être
faites on a porté sur le moment la
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est aussi de
sortir d'une logique qui est celle des
deux ponctuel car on est dans une
situation où la pauvreté de la précarité
la pauvreté devienne structurel et il
est difficile pour aussi notre
association d'arriver à se projeter sur
des politiques ou des aides publiques
qui sont qui ont répondu à un moment
donné à la question de la crise mais
quand une crise s'installe c'est une
réponse structurelle qui doit être
apportée aussi merci beaucoup
sébastien tatlot d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire national du secours populaire